Harry we've been talking about how
interested Paul is in exceedingly
practical embodied human life not just
in some kind of abstract spiritual realm
and in chapters five and six to which we
now turn that becomes especially clear
he's worried about issues of sexual
morality and he's worried about the very
American issue of how often do you go to
court to sue somebody and why let's
start with the sexual issues of what's
the what's got him so you know I'd Paul
is riled up what is riled up at the
beginning of chapter four Paul is
concerned yes that's clear and we
finally have a presenting issue as
opposed to the rather generic language
about wisdom and Apostleship and
everything else in the first four
chapters yeah he tells us at the
beginning of chapter five it is actually
reported that there was sexual
immorality among you of a kind that is
not found even among pagans maybe maybe
not yeah but for a man is living with
his father's wife now what's going on
here probably not incest which is
probably his father's second marriage
perhaps and I think what what is
motivating Paul's I are here is his
Jewish heritage coming out of a text
like Leviticus 18 which stipulates what
appropriate sexual behavior is and
Leviticus 18 8 says you shall not
uncover the nakedness of your father's
wife it is the nakedness of your father
and presumably that's not your mother
specified in another right another wife
so this is a kind of behavior that would
be prohibited by Torah so despite the
fact that Paul will say and probably has
said to the Corinthians that they are
not bound by Jewish Torah here this is a
fun very well ethical issue and you just
don't do it now
why is the Corinthians think they have
authorization to do it and why do they
boast about it even more bizarrely I
think right and I think we find the
answer to that question in the next
chapter after he deals a little bit with
the lawsuit issue but sex is on his mind
in both of these chapters 5 and 6 and
the purest possible way that's right of
course
but in chapter 6 verse 12 he apparently
is quoting a slogan that's current in
the
Corinthian community all things are
lawful for me now where would they get
that idea probably from hell so nothing
like solutions to create problems and
solution that Paul has that who hinted
earlier on in one of our conversations
the solution is Paul's gospel look they
have been called the freedom and this
freedom that makes all things possible
including dining with the Jews and
Gentiles and the Corinthians are hearing
this is it it makes it old anything goes
something that effect so what what Paul
is fundamentally arguing for here I
think in chapters five and six on the
issue of sexuality is that judgments
about sexual behavior are indeed matters
of Christian concern and as we know
Christians have argued about specific
judgments about sexual behavior and this
still is a matter that divides churches
or what that Christian should be
concerned with it I think is a matter
beyond dispute
yeah Paul's own sexual morality is
coming out of his biblical heritage
right and it strongly condemns not only
this particular act but sorts of other
things that he just lists yeah in
chapter 6 verse 9 for instance
fornication and adultery and male
prostitution yatra or in general at the
end of chapter 6 verses 17 where he
talks about fornication got it yeah and
we come back to our temple again yeah
and there we bring up the temple
language a body lying there so Paul
wants to insist that sex like just about
everything else that humans engage in is
a matter of appropriate consideration
for moral reflection on info reflection
within this community
yeah there's no there is no realm in
Paul and this is one of the things I
like about it that's actually free of
responsibility to God there's not
there's not this set of issues that are
kind of indifferent in terms of the way
he thinks that I think he thinks that
all of creation is being redeemed by God
in Jesus Christ and therefore what we do
with all of our creation is a matter of
Christian responsibility not simply a
individual choice that's tough for us
but I think it's important for him and
using this language of sanctification as
a way of getting a job that God's will
is not only to be in a kind of vague
relationship with everybody but that
it's a trance
moment of relationship a relationship
that lends holiness to individuals into
communities and he's going to insist on
this again in Chapter seven when he
talks about marriage and he wants to
preserve the holiness of the community
which brings me to one of my puzzles
about this I've been I've been a pastor
of three different churches all of them
seeking to be faithful all of them
reading the Bible all of them reading
Paul all of them worried about sexual
ethics because we are in our time not
once has anybody ever suggested we
should ask anybody to leave the church
on issues of sexual morality we just we
just we think about it in the abstract
but we've never thought it was our job
as Christian people to say no this has
gone too far out you go what is there a
way that faithful Christian people today
can still be worried about church
discipline the way he is and we are we
simply do now well Paul definitely
incidentally that but the guy who's
sleeping with her father's wife is to be
expelled out he goes the interesting to
know whether the Corinthian said okay
said when I thought at this point
exactly where the gyri pension comes
back yeah yeah and there were some hints
in 2nd Corinthians that there might have
been a big blowup over there
but Paul certainly wants to draw a
boundary here and this has to do with
his notion of sanctification and
holiness too and that might be the
downside of using that kind of language
that sanctification and holiness usually
is something that takes place within
certain set boundaries and so Paul might
not be totally faithful to his own
gospel here of extending God's yeah to
everything and to the redeeming power of
God can be at work well I think Paul
does hope that God's redeeming power I
think I think he's not I think he's not
actually condemning this man to hell no
I think he's removing him from church in
hopes that he'll repent and so the
spirit may be safe out there I think
this is but it's a kind of harsh move
and so far most of us would not be
content with although this raises the
larger issue of are there any sorts of
ethical issues on which we might want to
expel no absolutely a congregation or
take some sort of German well it's the
place where I think back to it is in
terms of race relations where I'm now
living in the south and there are
courageous pastors who lost their
pulpits and I'm sure they're great just
lay people who lost their status as
deacons or elders by their insistence
that the church
to be integrated and that was seen as
violating their sense of the white
sanctity of that community and and where
lines got drawn so it's very hard I'm
I'm a star of inclusiveness I wander
around the country talking about the
inclusive gospel and getting to great
applause especially from moderates and
liberals but sometimes I have to call my
attention to my own attention to the
fact that Paul says there are lines it's
not true that the sanctity of the church
allows just anything right this comes
home to me as a Catholic with all of the
problems that the Catholic Church is
having in this country over priestly
pedophilia yeah and I think they the
action of the church within the last
couple of years to insist that there are
lines you can't cross right yeah an
appropriate thing to do yeah it's a
matter of discernment from stuff needs
to be done lawsuits once it doesn't go
well I intend to sue you even though
we're both Christians but it seems to me
will be entirely your fault
what would Paul think about that he
would definitely disapprove like darling
okay who tells us at the beginning of
chapter 6 that people ought not be going
to courts that they ought to try to
solve their problems within within the
community you know this is one of those
cases where I think Paul's advice is
utterly unrealistic for our environment
but still advise that we Martian air
make yeah with some degree yes I think
of a lot of my friends in both in
dealing with marital issues or dealing
with even questions of civil law who
found mediation and useful and what
mechanism and you know Christians ought
to be thinking about ways in which the
adversarial situation of a court might
not be the best way to solve the problem
and to look for ways that are compatible
with fundamental Christian commitments I
think that's that's what Paul's message
says to me I think that's important I
think we do have a tendency more than
ever in our communities to assume that
the solution to any problem is to find
someone to blame and then sue as quickly
as we can and I in some ways litigation
has taken the place of theology for us
we no longer ask what God's doing we try
to figure out who we can blame and get
money out of and I think in an odd way
Paul not knowing that world nonetheless
anticipates it and
for Christian people back off a little
bit and see if there aren't other ways
that would be faithful that are equally
appropriate what do you make of Paul's
remark do you not know that we had a
judge angels I leave that to your
extraordinarily great wisdom on this
matter I don't look forward to it I have
out enough time judging humans I suspect
when the angel thing comes don't think
myself it's a this is one of those
moments where we realize that we think
we know what Paul's world is like and we
don't really I mean it's not the only
place in this book where angels pop up
in places we wouldn't have expected in
first Corinthians 15 people are being
baptized for the dead I mean they're
just we think that he sounds kind of
like a rational 21st century Protestant
a Roman Catholic and we kind of know how
it works and then we suddenly realized
there's a whole spiritual world out
there in which he also lives and we have
hints of it but the things he gets up
and thinks in the morning we have only
and so one of them is there those angels
up there and it's eschatological
language again this it's back to being
chosen what you started with we are the
chosen people we are so chosen that
finally we will even be called upon to
judge angels if you're that chosen you
better be same saintly thanked about
well I look forward to their next
conversation about angels in Chapter I
do too I don't look forward to my actual
judging of the angels or